[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for
tersely fees i'm sean evans coming at
you from Manhattan's Lower East Side I'm
joined by a couple of New York City's
most exciting young MCS wiki and your
old drew I'm gonna train 86 and it's
pegasi visit my mom 40 seconds - mm when
you have to get riff on the dog promise
proper christopher wallace resort
impalas are also super Riley and today
we're going to be digging into one of
the city's most time-honored
institutions and that's the local
neighborhood bodega we're outside of
stop one belly to get the corner store
cheat code from a couple of bodega
regular guys ready to get it going in
the school every city has convenience
stores every city has delis but the
bodega seems to be such a uniquely New
York phenomenon you have any opinion on
why you think that is
it's like the supermarket at the block
like the Ox feed the block mean people
outside in New York who grew up or
hip-hop I think they're like New York
rats invented bodegas and like all the
stuff that they wrap it about like it's
something you know that's all I'm the
only I would like to fish in the water
you know me I didn't even know like it
was that big of a deal to be from the
market I left the world can you give me
the bodega 101 the dues that don't know
don't touch the cap you know right like
it can't be you make a dent in fact oh
I'm trying to stay off the swings you
know meaning like stuff like this like
drinks coffee cakes yeah this just takes
me back to a dark period of my life
roses smoking a lot of dirt weed and
like this week of munchies prostate away
from that if you're trying to buy
something illegal don't ask if it
happens put your money on the table
the main use it is you got those dick
tools those guys who grew up in it what
role if any did it play in your music
career you don't think about it yeah
because it's like of course you're gonna
rob like that and in fact
my new [ __ ] I got coming out I have to
shout out from your finger like big
dudes in a deli yeah I mean I mean the
way I paid for my first project I went
to the bodega were clean dice cookie
still a case we get with gambling use
that to pay for the session for the core
biology course love it
it's just a part of life and I rap about
my life well there's nothing worse than
somebody go window shoppers I think that
we should buy some [ __ ] before we get
kicked out of here we're gonna be doing
this five pound lunch style very grime
report TV episode
cool phone minty server 47 everybody's
got $10 it's the first we feast per diem
really making the most over here
lifestyles of the rich and famous
everybody gets 10 bucks we're going to
see how far we can stretch it let's do
some shopping it is
are your winner breakfast session right
now
that much a bit you know more Memphis
it's good we got the orange juice
Towson Valentine's preferable for tea
for me I think first things first we're
going to go with 22 hours of stay nice
why because it's Friday don't drink the
plastic for dinner
drop your health conscious for breakfast
you got to mix them together you know
let's drink it to the label and then
just pour it in
it's like a mimosa basic no sometimes
you can mix with 42 v8 that's a 48 I'm
[ __ ] undershoot that was way we got to
go back go back back
I get the free thing to Chips Ahoy yeah
we'll see the chair you can get this for
later
you can't pose with nothing else to
practice is it cool I mean anyone that
grew up knows that I would tweet to it
want to go for something nostalgic all
right [ __ ] the chips that's building the
team used to eat things in junior high
school worship do just get beat off for
the last cookie issue like that
gotta get read because you know that's
my color big koala yummies guy over here
only get candy products that agree I
don't see them here so I'm going to go
with this the hello Panda and chocolate
filled cookies let me think about must
view this is your dollars I think I got
money to spend and then I feel like I
have space in my budget now for one
luxury item for the Spacely and I mean
that the thing you can give your grocery
shopping in the deli it's not like you
don't got to go nowhere else I mean and
I'm hitting up the icy station
you're almost risk will do but I try not
to spend out much money
but they told me to give me $10 off
about the pocket I'll [ __ ]
how's the order over here is yours there
this is mine here you got a 40 ounce
beer 375 all of you Tropicana tamales
how did you for 120 of power straws here
for a dollar and to Capri Sun Goes Down
so you got the spirits 22 ounce I've got
this cookies for 199 and this I see for
a Java 52 Oreos for $2 Welch's fruit -
$4 25 cookies here for a dollar
the real chips 50 Cent's and another
chip Savoy five dollars comes up to 575
eight dollars 95
so I watch for three dice three dice it
three / delta T the change will be 90
suppose you're maybe I'm serious god we
wrote this response water-bound economic
decisions right there alright so we have
our drinks we have a snack we have a
bodega crash course nothing left now but
to find a soup for lunch you guys ready
yes yeah stall baby
[Music]
yo we still roads rule so my Medwick our
head was sawing in the wild we just
bought some stuff from the store buy my
[ __ ] on iTunes all that
come see us live we rock it soon